un nuevo capítulo para la política
italiana pero sin quemar libros ni
puentes Georgia melón y presentó el
martes su programa de gobierno ante el
parlamento italiano tratando de asegurar
a los nerviosos internacionales que a
pesar de las raíces postfasistas de su
partido seguirá siendo un socio sólido
tanto para la Unión Europea como para la
otan nunca he tenido ninguna simpatía ni
he sentido ninguna cercanía por los
regímenes no democráticos por ningún
régimen incluido el fascismo siempre he
considerado las leyes raciales de 1938
como el momento más bajo de la historia
de Italia una desgracia Que marcará
nuestro país para siempre
meloni de 45 años la primera mujer en
ocupar el cargo en Italia ha sido a
menudo muy crítica con la política
europea dominante sorprendió a sus
socios de coalición al reunirse con el
presidente de Francia de Manuel macrón
el domingo por la noche mientras el
mandatario fuertemente para Unión
Europea estaba en Roma para una cumbre
de paz y aunque esos socios de coalición
el ex ministro del interior Mateo
salvini de la liga de extrema derecha y
Silvio berlusconi de Forza Italia han
sido ambos cercanos a Vladimir Putin
ella pidió que se siga apoyando a
Ucrania contra la invasión ilegal de
Rusia espera renegociar varios puntos
con la Unión Europea desde la
participación del país en los fondos
europeos de recuperación de covid hasta
la adopción de una línea más dura a la
hora de detener las embarcaciones de
migrantes que cruzan el mar Mediterráneo
desde el norte de África el programa de
su gobierno obtuvo el martes un voto de
confianza en la cámara baja del
parlamento italiano se espera que el
trámite se complete el miércoles en el
senado